beijing
acknowledges now that they don't think
it originated in that market well it may
not have originated in the market
um but it certainly could have i think
you could say we don't know how and
where it originated
you can't quit
the wet market theory so why should we
trust them now
here now to react a man in the middle of
it senator from kentucky rand paul
senator thank you so much for joining
fox news primetime really appreciate it
thanks for having me absolutely so we
have the introduction of omicron you
have the way in which the south african
doctor has characterized it which is
thankfully
unusually mild yet when you watch the
media elected officials they're on
hyperdrive on the fear index your
response to where we are right now with
this now third iteration
you know i think the hysteria gets the
better of the media and we need to calm
down take a breath and see what this is
now if it turned out to be worse then
we're going to have to you know make
some decisions but it looks like and
this is what happens a lot of times with
viruses as they mutate they become more
transmissible more easily contagious but
a lot of times they become less deadly
and that's what the reports are at least
the initial reports from south africa
are more transmissible but fortunately
less deadly senator do you agree or
disagree with the decision to uh
institute a travel ban uh in south
africa and surrounding countries
remember joe biden characterized it as
utterly racist against black and brown
people for donald trump to do so now
they're doing it but it could wait until
monday
it's incredibly incredibly hypocritical
for him to have criticized trump and now
do the same thing but if you ask me just
about bans bans in general don't work
almost nothing that man does works to
slow down the spread of a virus the
vaccine works and natural immunity
everything else we've done
could have possibly delayed it a little
bit but really probably has done little
if nothing to changing the trajectory of
things every time we've instituted a
mandate whether it be mass or social
distancing or how many people can be a
restaurant or how late you can get a
drink at a bar none of this affected the
trajectory of the virus the virus has
moved the numbers of viral infections
per day have moved
regardless of what man has tried to do
other than the vaccine the vaccine was
working pretty well in may of april but
now the vaccine isn't working so well
and the virus is escaping it so the one
thing they could do they're not doing
and that is we should allow for a new
vaccine to be introduced they have it
waiting but they're not doing anything
to introduce the new vaccine why would
they not introduce a new vaccine
you know that's a good question i i
think well maybe they bought a lot of
the old one they haven't used it up yet
and maybe they're trying to be frugal
maybe have somebody has something
invested in the old one but the old one
isn't working so well it probably does
reduce your risk of severe
hospitalization still and death but it's
not really fighting off the virus at a
level where we really could change the
trajectory
in april and may of this year we got
down to less than 10 000 cases a day we
did that when the first vaccine was very
very effective when we got the delta
variant now that it dominates the
vaccine isn't as in fact as effective as
it was and we have a new vaccine it's
sitting there we approve a new vaccine
for the flu they criticize trump
endlessly for you know why does he do uh
they've actually we got a vaccine within
one year and why aren't they doing
anything to introduce a new vaccine or
to allow get the red tape out of the way
let's get the new vaccine out and see if
that helps it's good it's a good point
the guy who made a living getting rid of
red tape got rid of it he gets no credit
for it now they can't seem to do
anything similar now that we're in the
middle of it you alluded to it uh
senator the fact that things that we did
in 2019 don't match the reality of where
we are in 2021. well one man's been
there the entire time you know well dr
anthony fauci he had an interview on
sunday where he declared that he
represents science take a listen
anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct
anti-science
flavor to this
so if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about but if they get up and
really aim their bullets at tony fauci
well people can recognize there's a
person there so it's easy to criticize
but they're really criticizing science
because i represent science
he represents science i'm feeling he
might be talking about you senator
you know when a government bureaucrat
has the audacity the arrogance to say
they represent all of science we should
be running the other way it conjures up
images of the medieval church you know
in their repression of science science
has nothing to do with having obedience
to any kind of government dogma and you
have to realize that most of what falci
talks about isn't science he's not
talking about a study on this or a study
of that he's talking about wear a mask
well when you talk about the
peer-reviewed studies of mask there was
one done in denmark showed that it
didn't work when you look at all of
sweden 1.8 million children have not
been wearing masks for the last two
years they've had zero covet deaths and
you say well have the teachers been
infected well it turns out the teachers
are infected at the same rate as the
rest of the public so they've they've
had no mass for a year year and a half
and it has worked and that's a whole
country and there's no real discussion
of this because if you question him and
really that's public policy that's not
science it's public policy backed by
some science but if you question him oh
somehow you are questioning science
because he represents all science that
is incredibly arrogant
it really is it conjures up sylvester
stallone i am the law you know at one
point it becomes
completely absurd and as you pointed out
very very arrogant senator rand paul
thank you so much for breaking down
actual science for us